Any tips on PMR, not medical advice, but for an 83-year-old patient?
Again, with PMR, you have to get to the cause of things.
Like any disorder you have going on, you want to get to the cause of things.
From a medical standpoint, with polymyalgia, any polymyalgia issues, they're typically just going to give you paid medication.
From a functional standpoint, it's many times looked at as a chronic inflammation issue.
Looking at blood work, you might find an increase in your inflammatory markers.
Typically, blood work that's done on these type of people is just going to be a CVC in a complete metabolic panel.
This is where I advocate highly into looking at autoimmune panels too.
If you have antibodies to self-tissue, that's going to be a huge issue that you want to deal with.
So digging into deeper blood work is going to be the key to that.
That's really, honestly, the key to so many disorders.
So many people are struggling with things that I hear are...
I've been to multiple doctors, and I don't know how to treat this.
Nobody's gotten to the bottom of this, and then you ask for that patient to send in all their labs.
And it's amazing how few labs, many times, that people have,
or all they've had done as a CVC in a complete metabolic panel through their GP.
And sometimes it's really disturbing because sometimes they've even had gross abnormalities and that,
and nothing was investigated and nothing was moved forward.
Many times, people can have overwhelming symptoms because they have an ademia,
but then nobody ever addresses the ademia.
Back to another question on the Facebook page, any dietary changes for PMR.
Just overall, there's some inflammatory process going on.
So a person would do much better going on an anti-inflammatory diet.
You could just Google an anti-inflammatory diet that would help.
I would highly suspect, though, that there's specific dietary antibodies.
Common with this would be gluten.
Also, possibly lectins could be an issue because you could actually have rheumatoid factor positive.
That would be the benefit of doing an antibody test.
And then if R.A. is antibodies are present, then I would say lectins can be a big culprit.
So you could look up a lectin, a low lectin diet or a lectin-free diet,
certainly gluten-free diet and just overall just an anti-inflammatory diet.
And like anything, when you have an uptick of inflammation, systemic inflammation in the body,
you always have to think that there's inflammation in the gut.
That's why food sensitivity panels, like a Cyrexarate 10,
would be the right choice in something like this because it's amazing what you could do
when you calm down the gut, what you could do from a systemic standpoint.
I've had people with inflammatory arithritis, you know,
they were diagnosed with psoriatic arthritis or rheumatoid arthritis.
It would just clean up the gut and did a Cyrexarate 10,
cleaned up the gut with diets, things that are causing inflammation that got
all their symptoms calm down. Now, the longer you have an arthritis like that,
you have bony changes. We're never going to change those bony changes,
but if you could decrease the inflammation, you could decrease, you know, 95% of the patient's symptoms.
So like anything, you're always looking for the cause. You're always looking for the source.
So you're going to be digging to that source and, you know,
it's not enough to say, oh, you have inflammation.
Your C-reactor protein is high, your hybridid is high.
You know, something like that, you want to go, okay, well, why is that?
You know, what is the cause of that as well?
So digging to that is important.